germany
june 1921 to november 1923
highest monthly inflation rate over 30
000
time required for prices to double every
few days
during world war one like many countries
germany then called the weimar republic
suspended its ghost center to fund the
war effort
based on the belief that they were going
to win the war and pay for it by
plundering their enemies
that plan obviously didn't work out so
after the war they were left shackled
with not only their own war deaths
but were also fined 132 billion gold
marks in reparations by the treaty of
versailles
the equivalent of about 269 billion
dollars today
the first payment of that war guilt came
due in june 1921.
the problem was the treaty didn't allow
germany to make payments in its own
currency
so germany had no choice but to exchange
their german marks for other respected
currencies at really bad exchange rates
so what was the solution well we're off
the gold standard
so let's just print more money and print
they did
that printed money was used to buy
foreign currency that foreign currency
was used to pay off their war
reparations
and soon germany was buying foreign
currency at any price because why not
all they had to do was print more money
so in just a little over a year later
the german mark was already practically
worthless
a fifty thousand dollar bill turned into
a five hundred thousand dollar bill to a
five million dollar bill to a 50 million
bill to 500 million to 5 billion to 50
billion to 500 billion to 5 trillion to
a 50 trillion dollar bill
bills that were worth more of its weight
as wood fire than as a medium of
exchange
a loaf of bread that cost 160 marks by
the end of 1922
skyrocketed to 200 billion marks just a
year
later although germany was the most
infamous case of hyperinflation
it is far from the worst
this episode is brought to you by trends
learning about thousands of great
business ideas that you can take
advantage of
long before you read about them in the
wall street journal i personally enjoyed
reading about the massive growth around
apps popping up on slack's platform
who would have thought that slack apps
would grow into a 300 million dollar
market
stay tuned to the end to learn more or
feel free to discover your next big idea
right now by going to trends.co
jake tran try out trends for an entire
week all for just one dollar
again that's trends.co jaketran the link
is also in the video description below
hungary august 1945 to july 1946
highest monthly rate of inflation 4.19
times 10 to the 16th power
or this giant number equivalent daily
inflation rate
207 time required for prices to double
15 hours after world war ii like many
countries
hungary was left in shambles their
industries were crippled and what
remained of their assets were seized by
both sides of the war
so the amount of goods produced went
down but the amount of money in
circulation stayed the same
so inflation but instead of trying to
reduce the inflation by reducing the
amount of money in circulation which
could have made the already dead economy
worse
hungary took a different approach the
government intentionally caused
inflation by printing literally as much
money as they could
what started out as 25 billion pengate
in july 1945
grew to 1.6 trillion penguins six months
later
then just four months after that the
money supply grew to 65 quadrillion
which is a million billion then just
another two months after that
to 47 septillion that's 47 trillion
trillion
to make this a little bit more
comprehensible something that cost 379
pengui in september 1945
went up to a trillion trillion 10 months
later
at one point the government had to stop
collecting taxes because if they were
late by just one day
it would have wiped out the value of the
taxes the government collected
needless to say this would go down in
history as the worst case of
hyperinflation ever
[Music]
yugoslavia april 1992 to january 1994
highest monthly inflation rate 313
million percent
equivalent daily inflation rate 64.6
time required for prices to double 1.4
days
yugoslavia was a nation born in the wake
of world war ii that was made up of
these modern day countries
during the early days of the breakup of
these nation states in the early 1990s
the second worst case of hyperinflation
occurred far worse than the weimar
republic
yet it seems to have slipped under the
public's consciousness
at its peak in january 1994 the official
monthly inflation rate was 313 million
percent
or four times higher than the weimar
republic and the results were
devastating
people's income dropped more than 50
percent they couldn't afford food if
there was any to be bought
bread lines foreign gas stations were
closed foreign exchange black markets
emerged
to put it into perspective imagine the
money you have in your bank account
right now
then imagine moving the decimal point 22
places to the left
then imagine trying to buy something
then imagine trying to survive through
this for two years straight
from the start of 2020 to the end of
2021 for example
zimbabwe march 2007 to november 2008
highest monthly inflation rate 79.6
billion percent
equivalent daily inflation rate 98
time required for prices to double 24.7
hours after zimbabwe gained independence
from the united kingdom in 1980
this opened up a whole new profession
politicians
politicians whose first priority has
always been to secure those votes to
secure their seat in power
and how do you secure that public
support as a politician who has control
over the government spending
offer free stuff so offer free stuff
they did which created a spending
problem for their government
add on top of that a ton of other stuff
like the government seizing farms from
white farmers and giving it to black
farmers
that didn't know how to farm which
created a food shortage the situation
was made worse by costly participation
in the congo war in 1998
and sanctions against robert mugabe's
government in 2002.
the government blames its financial
problems on sanctions imposed by the eu
and u.s during mugabe's reign the
banking sector collapsing in the money
printer going bur
and you have the perfect storm to
nurture some hyperinflation
the general rule of thumb is that
hyperinflation is when the monthly
inflation rate is above 50
and since 1998 zimbabwe has been
hovering around a 50
annual inflation rate mix in zimbabwe
central bank continuing to tinker with
the economy to try to slow down
inflation
and by march 2007 the country was
experiencing full-blown hyperinflation
with again a peaking around 79.6 billion
percent
a month prices in shops would go up
several times a day
water and power cuts happened often and
there were cues at banks
petrol stations and severe shortages of
food in supermarkets
a problem they're still struggling on
and off with to this day this year
inflation is hovering at around 300
percent that was the latest figure
before zimbabwe's finance minister put a
moratorium on publishing numbers
until next year
venezuela 2013 to the day a situation
caused by both political and economic
reasons that range from the government
controlling parts of the economy
shortages of food electricity medicine
riots and political instability that's
them from that
oil revenue tanking even though they
have some of the largest oil reserves on
the planet
gasoline has been in short supply there
for years
the shortage has now reached
unsustainable levels
and is hitting the capital caracas in
the middle of a pandemic
economic sanctions from the us and more
with hyperinflation starting at
modest levels in 2013 to peaking at
around 1.6
million percent in 2018 with the
venezuelan central bank estimating that
the currency was inflated by 53.8
million percent
between 2006 and april 2019.
there's no coffee no flour no oil no
butter no corn flakes
there are a lot of food products missing
that aren't luxuries just normal food
they were able to tame the
hyperinflation back down to better
levels in the low thousands of percent
in recent years
but that still means that for the
average everyday shopper on the streets
prices for goods are doubling every few
weeks one woman said
everything is rising so quickly that
what i deposit in my account doesn't buy
anything
all we can do is eat less and stretch
what we have
which brings us to today in the west
[Music]
the united states january 6 2020 to
january 4 2021
coming straight from the fed we started
this period with around 4 trillion u.s
dollars in the system
one year later that number is at 6.7
trillion dollars
meaning that over 40 percent of all us
dollars were printed in just the last 12
months
well we've had an incredible surge in
government spending
a lot of it related of course to kova 19
and to the ordered you know economic
shutdown
and the fact that a lot of people were
no longer out there earning money
and so the government looked to replace
what people were no longer earning
by printing money which is what they did
you had all this government spending
but there were no additional tax hikes
to
cover the cost nor did the government
try to prioritize any of its spending
it didn't say well maybe we should spend
less on the military
so we have more to spend on fighting the
pandemic right they didn't budget
uh their resources they just said well
we're just gonna spend more money
on the pandemic but we're not gonna
spend less on anything else
and we're not going to raise anybody's
taxes to pay for it so
where did all the government spending
come from it doesn't come
from you know thin air the money has to
come from somewhere and if they're not
going to make room in the budget by
cutting spending
if they're not going to increase taxes
to get additional revenue
well then they just crank up the
printing process so that's where all
this new money came from
the government printed it and spent it
into circulation
through all these programs and from the
looks of it no one seems to be in a rush
to slow things down
a sweeping nearly 2 trillion relief
package
to tackle this pandemic one of the
largest in our nation's history
in fact no one is really talking about
this at all and right now nobody seems
to think that this is a problem
people seem to think that we've stumbled
on the equivalent of a monetary
fountain of youth people like to call it
modern monetary theory
which is we can have whatever we want as
long as government prints the money to
pay for it
that there's no limit that government is
free
as long as they print money now of
course and strangely enough
we haven't seen much inflation for
everyday goods like gas and food prices
definitely haven't gone up anywhere near
40 percent
and other countries seem to be following
suit
so the question remains where is the
inflation
the reason why we haven't seen inflation
yet is because the amount of money being
printed is only one of the factors that
contributes to inflation
to get inflation here's everything you
need number one
industrial output how much stuff an
economy makes
the more stuff the more supply which
equals lower prices
the less stuff the higher the prices
number two employment
too much employment leaves employers
fighting over workers which leads to
higher wages which leads to higher
prices
too little employment leads to employees
fighting over jobs
which leads to lower wages which leads
to lower prices
number three the money supply the main
topic of this video and probably the
easiest to understand
the more money in an economy equals
higher prices as long as the economy is
producing the same amount of stuff or
less stuff
and number four if the money is
exchanging hands and if so how fast
also known as the velocity of money if
you print a bunch of money but that
money is spent on food instead of gas
food is going to experience inflation
but gas isn't
if you want a more detailed explanation
of this i highly recommend you watch the
video by economics explained on the
subject
it will be linked below and in our case
right now the money supply has shot up a
ridiculous amount
but the other factors have been keeping
inflation down
industrial output it's been down from
businesses not being able to operate
which leads to less stuff but there's
also less demand from you and i to buy
those things
so its impact on how much inflation we
have is kind of neutral
employment has also definitely taken a
hit and with less employment comes lower
wages
which means lower prices not inflation
and the velocity of money
it's pretty slow for everyone with all
the uncertainty in the air people don't
want to spend money right now if they
don't know if they're going to be able
to keep their job or find a new one
and i think the reason for that is a lot
of the money that we print as is always
the case ends up getting exported
if you look at our trade deficits they
served to record territory especially
in goods where we had all-time record
high trade deficits so a lot of that
money got exported
and it wasn't here in the u.s where it
would have been used to bid up
the price of goods and and services but
you know what they are going to spend
money on
things that only go up like tesla stock
every other stock real
estate and bitcoin so we are seeing
plenty of inflation happening right now
the s p 500 has seen around a 70
increase since its crash in march
the same exact period all these new us
dollars were printed home prices have
gone up by 8
since january which is higher than usual
and pretty much everyone and their mom
knows how well bitcoin has been doing
but instead of calling it inflation we
call it the stock market rally the real
estate boom
kryptos time to shine or the great
crypto bubble depending on who you ask
when inflation pushes up asset prices
people don't complain because the people
that own those assets of course feel
much richer
right now the downward pressures are
counteracting the upward pressures
and we are in a fragile equilibrium so
inflation can work its way into the
economy through various
methods and so prices can be affected in
different ways but
ultimately it's consumer prices
that are where all the inflation ends up
once it you know finishes with making
its way through the economy because
that's really all everybody wants i mean
people don't buy stocks because they
want to own stocks
they buy stocks because they think
they'll be able to buy more consumer
goods
with the profits from their stocks but
ultimately those profits have to be
realized
and then they have to be spent on
consumer goods and
the price of those goods can go up which
begs the question
should the money printer keep going bur
can it keep going burr
and i ultimately think we're going to
see a real shock
in terms of how high consumer prices are
going to rise
so you think that's how it's going to
end up with all this money printing it's
eventually going to hit consumer prices
well it always does i mean that's like
the final resting place for inflation
is in the end product which is in
consumer goods but
those on the side are printing more and
more money spending more and more money
and not worrying about how much debt we
have
the modern monetary theory camp have an
interesting argument their main thing is
that since the government is the issuer
of money the creator of money
they don't have to worry very much about
spending a lot having too much debt
unlike people and businesses like us
who are the users of money because they
can always print more to make the debt
payments
the line you want to draw between the
federal government
let's say of the united states of
america and everybody else
that line that distinguishes their
fiscal capacities their
spending capacities from ours is really
down to the fact that they can
issue our currency the us dollar and the
rest of us
can if a government issues its own
currency
imposes tax liabilities or other kinds
of liabilities in that currency
spends only in its own currency and
issues debt
only in its own currency then it
basically can never run out of money
that is the basic of the argument
with the only limit to how much money
the government can spend borrow and
print
being the amount of stuff there is out
there for the government to spend money
on
the limit would be the resources
available
for the government to hire or purchase
the government can't run out of finance
right but the united states could run
out of
resources that are available once that
supply gets low
then we'll see prices rise and inflation
rise and if that's the case
we can spend borrow and print a lot more
than where we're at right now before
there's too much inflation
assuming that's true then we have a
social responsibility to offer things
like the government guaranteeing
everyone has a job
the green new deal stimulus checks
whatever the one that mmt
is most associated with is the job
guarantee program
an unconditional universal offer of a
job to anyone who wants to work
and the fact of the matter is this is
kind of how the world works right now
people think that we're we're describing
a new policy we're not
we are describing reality we're
describing the way the u.s
government spends the way the british
government spends
but should this be how the world works
in the first place
should we just accept that the
government should have a monopoly on
money in the first place
one way to think about it is the
government has a monopoly on a certain
thing
and so then why don't we get rid of that
right if the government right now you
know
soviet union if they had a monopoly on
agricultural output
you know yeah there'd be an economist in
there who could you know his career
would be writing books about
proper soviet planning of government uh
you know agricultural targets and so
forth but
surely you would think that the right
thing to do with for the concert would
be to focus on let's let's change this
system i don't understand why he's
focusing on certain things and just
conceding
yes the government's going to have
monopoly on money and so forth and
that's the way it is
if any other entity did the sorts of
things
and then tried to justify them or just
explain what they were doing
the way in his writings he talks about
what the government's doing clearly that
would be fraudulent
in the fundamental way that he came back
and said there's a distinction here that
you're not getting
murphy is that it's like there's a
scorekeeper and obviously
you know there's a distinction between
the people playing the game versus the
referee setting up the game
but then that just begs the question why
are we playing this game in the first
place
why is that guy the score keeper it's
because they have guns and are pointing
him nuts and saying you're going to play
this game
is because you're going to get shot
otherwise all right so since neither of
us is describing the way the world
literally is right this second we're
both
explaining tweaks we want to make in
this system it seems to me that's kind
of
a big deal our brains have not evolved
very much in the last 10 000 years
that means that the same humans that
caused all the other examples of
hyperinflation
those same politicians with the same
incentives that led to those disasters
are the same humans in our government
today with similar incentives
are those really the people you want in
control of the printing press
so before this interview before this
video i really tried to understand the
other side of the argument
the monetary theorist on the surface it
kind of makes sense what are your
thoughts on it
well it doesn't make sense beneath the
surface
and it doesn't make sense on the surface
either like no matter where you go
relative to the surface it doesn't make
any sense
but what is true though is that
if a government borrows in its own
currency
yes it can go deeper into debt
before suffering the consequences of its
profligacy
than a country that's borrowing in
somebody else's currency that it can't
print so
the day of reckoning will come later for
a country that's borrowing its own
currency but
because the day of reckoning comes later
the problems get much bigger before that
happens
so that means the ultimate consequences
are much more severe
so you get away with it for a little
longer but then the pain is worse
when you no longer get away with it
because the idea that you get away with
it
definitely is nonsense right the bills
have got to be paid
eventually and the longer you
procrastinate paying them
the bigger the bill is going to be but
when the government just prints money
and gives it to you right when you have
all these unemployed people
who are sitting at home just getting a
check from the government
they produced nothing they added no
goods or services
to the economy yet they can consume
goods and services
in the same proportions as if somebody
had actually done work
and actually been you know a productive
member of society
all this does is drive up prices because
if your work
adds to the goods and services and now
your help
you're consuming the goods and services
you help create that's fine
but if now you start consuming goods and
services yet you didn't help create any
of those goods and services you just
have more money
chasing a diminished supply of goods and
services
and prices are going to go up and
they're going to go up
like never before and the irony of all
of this
is that the federal reserve has been
promising
americans more inflation well that's one
promise that they're going to deliver on
in fact they're going to deliver on it
beyond their wildest expectations
when you give government power they
usually don't like to give it back
so do you think there's ever going to be
time where they're going to slow down
the money printer
or is it just going to continue forever
well they can't do it forever because at
some point the money has no value
and you know there's not much sense in
printing money that buys nothing
so at some point they're going to have
to turn off the presses
and in fact hopefully at some point
they're going to slow them down
quite a bit but you know we'll see how
long they can resist
doing that because doing it involves a
lot of pain
short-term pain economically politically
that
our leaders really don't want and of
course if you look at all
of the promises that they've made to the
voters that can't possibly be paid for
rather than admit that you know none of
this can
you know is affordable they can just
print the money
and and act as if you know the
government can provide these things
so you know given the the type of
leaders we have and
their philosophy and their the base you
know
there's a good chance that they're going
to push this as far as they can
i mean until the dollar has completely
collapsed and then they just can't get
away with it anymore
so before that happens there's really no
incentive for anybody to
change yeah because as long as they can
print money
and people will accept it and the value
doesn't go down too much
well they'll just keep doing it rather
than being honest with the public and
accepting the consequences
one of the best ways to protect yourself
against inflation and even
hyperinflation is to have
a great business because if you have the
next big thing that people need
you'll be protected in any business
environment that's where trends comes in
with trends you can discover emerging
industries before they become a big deal
just head over to the signal section and
feature eyes on the latest trending
sectors like niche sports
or psychedelic mushrooms which are being
used as a potential treatment for
depression
in addition to being the internet's most
undiscovered knowledge hub
trans is also home to a wonderful
community a community of makers
investors and not to mention hustling
entrepreneurs just like you and me
if you run a business or you're thinking
about starting one trends is a must-have
resource
discover your next big idea by starting
your one week trial of trends for the
grand sum of just one dollar
by going to trends.co jake tran the link
is also in the video description below
[Music]
oolong tea and mct oil not sponsored
peter schiff the guy you seen featured
in this video super cool guy someone
that i really like to listen to and take
into account his opinions along with
other people who have differing economic
opinions
so calm down especially you bitcoin boys
he's the guy in the video that you've
probably seen around i am the one
percent let's talk
and he's got a great podcast and youtube
channel that you can check out with the
links below
alright alright alright i am well aware
that there are a lot of plugs in this
video but this plug is very important i
decided at the last minute to post the
entire interviews i do for these videos
on a separate channel for you guys to
check out because it's not like i have a
lot of stuff on my plate or anything
so you can check out the entire peter
shift interview with the link in the
video description where we talk about a
ton of cool stuff like is it inevitable
that
more capitalistic individualistic
societies naturally decay
into more socialistic collectivist
societies
that would be linked below and it would
mean a ton if you guys subscribe to that
channel too
back to the other me if you are new here
we make video essays just like this one
every single week on the most thought
provoking controversial
interesting subjects in the world of
business every single week for free so
make sure you subscribe
to this channel too with the red button
below i believe
that's gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there as always and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign